lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
practicar el cálculo de la aproximación
del área bajo la curva y el uso de la
notación sigma en este contexto aquí
tenemos la gráfica de la función f x
igual a 1 + 0.1 x cuadrada es esta curva
que aparece aquí también tenemos estos
rectángulos como una aproximación del
área bajo la curva del área que se
encuentra por debajo de la gráfica de f
/ x igual a 0 y x igual a 8 y la manera
como haremos esta aproximación de
acuerdo a este diagrama es dividiendo el
área en estos cuatro rectángulos así es
que a este rectángulo le podemos llamar
rectángulo 1 a este rectángulo 2
rectángulo 3 y rectángulo 4 ya esta
altura pero veamos primero el intervalo
parece ser que cada uno de estos
rectángulos tiene una base de 2 el
intervalo de 0 a 8 lo hemos dividido en
cuatro secciones iguales así es que cada
sección tiene una longitud de 2 ahí
tenemos 22
2 y 2 y la altura del rectángulo
aparentemente se toma se calcula a
partir del punto medio
así es que entre el lado izquierdo y el
lado derecho de la base del rectángulo
tomaremos la altura a partir del punto
medio así tenemos que la altura aquí es
efe de 1 la altura aquí es efe de 3 la
altura de este rectángulo es efe de 5 y
finalmente la altura aquí es efe de 7
entonces en base a esta construcción que
tenemos aquí queremos usar la suma de
las áreas de estos 4 rectángulos para
aproximar el área bajo la curva como
podríamos establecer dicha suma
utilizando la notación sigma bien
queremos hacer la suma de las áreas de
estos 4 rectángulos eso podemos
escribirlo como la suma desde n igual a
1 hasta en igual a 4 son 4 rectángulos
aquí te invito a que le pongas pausa y
completes lo que viene aquí escríbelo en
términos de la función no es necesario
que lo escribas como 10.1 de algo al
cuadrado sino que puedes usar la
notación funcional
pongo que ya lo intentaste así es que
veamos para el primer rectángulo su área
la vamos a calcular como 2 que es la
base por la altura que es la función
evaluada en 1
así es que aquí podemos poner que es 2
por efe dn
para el segundo rectángulo tenemos que
también sería 2 que corresponde a la
base del rectángulo multiplicada por la
altura que es f evaluada en 3 ya que no
nos funciona fn porque n vale 2 y lo que
queremos es f de 3 tenemos que ver cómo
construimos este argumento a ver veamos
hagamos una tabla para ver esto en esta
tabla vamos a considerar entonces los
valores de n que es 1234 y los valores
de f dn bueno eso es lo que queremos
determinar así para en igual a uno la
altura si es f1 cuando n es igual a 2 la
altura correspondiente es f de 3 cuando
en es igual a 3
efe de 5 y cuando n es igual a 4
la altura es f de 7 y qué relación hay
entre n y el argumento bien parece ser
que cuando multiplicas por 2 y restas 1
obtienes el argumento a ver veamos 2 x 1
- 1 1 2 x 2 menos 13 2 por 3 menos 5 2
por 3 menos 15 2 por 4 menos 17 de tal
manera que el argumento de la función es
12 n 1 y el área de los rectángulos la
podemos calcular como la base que es 2
por la altura que es f de 12 ene - 12
por efe de 12 n 1 y aquí la tenemos
espero que te haya quedado claro cómo
relacionamos la notación sigma con lo
que estamos intentando hacer y ahora
divirtámonos un poco tratando de evaluar
esto de aquí obtener el resultado de
esta expresión esto es igual a 2
efe de 2 x 1 1/2 por efe de 1 + 2 por
efe de 2 x 24 menos uno efe de 3 más
cuando en es igual a 32 por efe de 5 más
cuando en es igual a 42 por efe de 72
por 48 menos 172 por f de 7 así es que
esto va a ser igual a vamos a tener que
evaluar varias veces esta expresión
déjame borrar esto de aquí para que
tenga más espacio se me hace que vamos a
tener que escribir bastantes cálculos
así es que esto va a ser igual a podemos
factorizar el 2 para empezar y f1 es uno
más punto uno por uno al cuadrado esto
es uno más
punto uno deja de poner lo mejor con
colores para que quede más claro que lo
que estoy haciendo
efe de 11.1 10.1 es 1.1
este de aquí efe de tres es uno más
punto uno por tres al cuadrado tres al
cuadrado es nueve esto es uno más punto
91.9 más 1.9 a eso le vamos a sumar f 5f
de 5 que es uno más punto uno por cinco
al cuadrado que es 25 por punto 1 es 2.5
más 13.5 y finalmente más
efe de 7 que es igual a 1.1 por 7 al
cuadrado que es 49.1 por 49 4.91 esto es
5.9 + 5.9 bien y ahora todo esto a
cuánto es igual veamos aquí podemos
sumar 1.1 más 1.9 esto es igual a 3
y por otro lado tenemos 3.5 5.9 y esto
es igual veamos 3.55 s 8.5 más punto
99.4 + 9.4 entonces y se viene esto a
ver 35 8.5 punto 91.4 89.4 por lo que
esto es igual a por cierto hay que
incluir el 2
así es que esto va a ser igual a 2 por
12.4 y 2 por 12.4 es igual a 24.8 que es
el valor de la aproximación no olvidemos
que esta es una estimación usando el
área de estos rectángulos para estimar
el valor del área bajo la curva entre x
igual a 0 y x igual a 8